demonstrators in Mexico City
they're protesting against Rising costs
of housing
the increase in rent and housing prices
is negatively affecting us as a local
community this woman has asked us not to
reveal her identity out of fear of
reprisal she says the housing crisis
goes beyond increasing prices
after her apartment building signed a
deal with the home share company Airbnb
she was given five days to move out
says short notice evictions are becoming
commonplace across the city
this is a matter of human dignity how
can someone come to your home in the
evening and say you have five days to
vacate
what do they expect us to do
in recent years Mexico City has seen a
large influx of foreign residents
the Mexican capital is now considered
one of the top five cities in the world
for remote workers and in agreement
signed last month between the city and
Airbnb seeks to attract even more
this is an invitation for workers from
the whole world to come live in Mexico
City a city that has it all
while the mayor's office says the city
hasn't seen a causal link between more
Airbnb rentals and higher rent prices
activists say a lack of Regulation has
allowed real estate companies to operate
like a cartel
via cartel because there is a fight over
control of territory we're talking about
an urban War where people are being
forcibly displaced this is a Northern
war and money is winning
activists say the formula is simple as
Mexico has sought to attract remote
workers with higher purchasing power
it's created more inequality for
Mexicans
protesters here in Mexico City say rent
prices are so high some are finding it
hard to find affordable housing at all
pushing many outside the city limits
residents who feel priced out of their
own City are calling on the government
to do more to guarantee affordable
housing and protect the rights of
tenants and homeowners
Al Jazeera Mexico City